j'ai retrouvé dans mon atelier un
baromètre de torricelli du nom de son
inventeur en 1644 c'est le premier
instrument qui a permis de mesurer la
pression atmosphérique et donc de
prévoir le temps qu'il va faire
car les phénomènes météorologiques sont
liées à la pression atmosphérique
il s'agit d'une colonne de verre d'un
mètre de hauteur fermé à son sommet avec
à la base une cuve qui contient du
mercure
quand le temps se gâte l'air est moins
dense la pression sur le mercure diminue
et la colonne des sens quand elle passe
sous la barre des 76 cm
c'est une dépression al'inverse quand il
fait beau
l'air est plus dense la pression sur le
mercure augmente et la colonne monde
qu'elle est au dessus de 67 cm c'est un
anticyclone
quoi qu'il en soit bon ou pas beau vous
connaissez la consigne
restez chez vous et n'oubliez pas nous
sommes tous confinés
mais en restant lien si vous avez aimé
cette capsule 2d confiné n'hésitez pas à
laisser un pouce bleus gens réalisent
une nouvelle chaque jour alors pour ne
pas les rater abonnez-vous et activer la
cloche
merci à toutes et à tous et à demain